c'est un peu spécial ses versions mots
que tu as regardé ce que ça donne
[Musique]
salut du bouffon tu as vu dans les
chiffres n est pas ta dans ta gueule on
va kiffer à coup sûr avec mes deux gars
bertron rôle ou et à rien de sa grand
mère
c'est hyper avec les lettres ben t'as
d'argent d'où ces parties de belote
[Musique]
ouais bah casar mois que ton cul là genf
lettre vas-y vas-y tu as posté un grand
g grootaers bah oui mais gros tarbes à
qui dire ça c'est mon petit coin du mot
bâtard bien sûr un très répandue dans le
9 3 le 7 8
le16 le24 ainsi que le 8 2 bien sûr sur
une petite préférence pour le mon cul
létard à cinq états unis ne sont pas les
seuls maltazard darweesh mais c'est sans
doute à gagner parce que tu n'as pas ta
gueule jul bois ton cadeau tu repars
avec une boîte de chocolats mon chéri
médias fait la dalle du coup je tape un
peu dans la nuit pour ma part j'attends
la sortie pour de foot départemental
jeunes voilà que la foire du chiffre et
des pandas dans ta gueule vous donne
rendez vous demain ce qui regarde pas
qui défonce la culture générale
[Applaudissements]